docteur suis pas malade mais je suis pas
bien je suis pas bien parce que sur le
plan sexuel
rien du tout quand j'aurai des garçons
ça me fait rien quand je vois des filles
enfin heureusement ça fait rien mais
pourtant il ya des jours il fait beau je
suis contente mais de la 6e' dr jeetoo
laboratoire sexuelle ils ont fait des
expériences sur des grenouilles vivantes
des trappes au marché pas quoi ils m'ont
dit ça fait rien du tout moi je suis pas
assez comme ça doctor parce que j'ai pas
de passé j'ai pas de présent j'ai pas
d'avenir
sur le plan sexuel je veux dire au point
de vue l'étude to save a obtenu santé je
suis ni bien ni mal mais ça c'est ma
bête noire witch est venu rgo e-mails au
service de l'amour
je suis toutes les recettes
aphrodisiaques ça me fait rien du tout
je comprends pas ce que j'ai eu mon bac
sexuelle sans problème c'est à dire il
ya beaucoup de théories beaucoup de
pratique je sais pas quand un garçon
s'approche de moi dans le métro ça me
fait des audits et statique
moi je m'en fous qu'on veut comme ça
tout seul mais l'art comme laisse
tranquille comme vous de la paix comme
laisse tout seul dans mon lundi comme
philippe chatel